i have to ask this because i didn't know
that you had like a bagpipe phase oh my
god which his family is scott our family
is scottish roots okay but a lot of
people have scottish roots that don't
play the bagpipe
but i really love the sound of bagpipes
it's beautiful and i i i got it on a you
know consignment you know yeah thrift so
whatever you call that this sheet when
you get used stuff you know the
newspaper yeah and you know remember
those
and i did for sale and i bought them
yeah and it and i asked i in my college
paper i advertised in the juan ads for
anybody that knew how to blow
[Laughter]
[Applause]
and then it said like this bagpipes
underneath that was my ass oh my god i
was like what kind of results happened
afterwards and then i got i said you
know how to vote
freshman wants to learn but freshman
wants to learn and my and my um
my housemates at my dorm they wouldn't
let me learn because it just sounds like
someone's being strangled what's so loud
yeah oh it's terrible yeah really bad
but it is beautiful and i was like
passing out from i didn't have the air
to blow through to sustain yeah yeah it
seems hard i like it too hard i know it
was too hard for me i'm glad i stuck
with the guitar you know i think we all
are yeah
i think that was a solid decision
[Music]